for years apple has been trying to break
into the automotive space from trying to
acquire tesla way back in 2013
to endlessly working on their own
electric vehicle after all of this time
it actually looks like the apple car is
finally taking shape as rumors are
suggesting a release between 2024 and
but considering the tremendous progress
from tesla neo
and rivian it seems like apple's
entrance into the eevee market will end
up like microsoft's entrance into
smartphones
however here's why you shouldn't
underestimate the apple car
starting off we have to keep in mind
that apple is by no means trying to
overtake major automakers
they're not trying to become the next
tesla or the next mercedes or anything
like that
all they're trying to do is carve out a
niche portion of the luxury car buying
market
with that being said let's jump into
their first advantage which is
their brand apple likely has the
strongest branding
and customer loyalty in the world as a
result
like tesla apple will not have to spend
very much money on marketing the apple
car
even today the apple car is years out
but major news sources are spending so
much money and resources covering apple
car rumors
leaks and features imagine when the
apple car
actually comes out the entire press will
be all over it
and don't forget about their own keynote
the keynote will likely end up trending
on youtube and it will get pushed all
throughout social media
considering this apple doesn't have to
worry about informing customers
about the car this however is not the
case with competitors like lucid
riven and fuel cell aside from a massive
marketing reach
apple also has extremely deep pockets as
of january
apple was holding 195.5 billion dollars
in cash
so they can easily afford to fully
develop their self-driving technology
before releasing it to the public while
tesla's autopilot software is awesome
it definitely has its issues and that's
to be expected
as it's just beta software apple however
will refuse to launch software software
until they get it nearly perfect and
they can afford to do this
as well something else to keep in mind
is that apple has access to the best
talent in the world
just like tesla not only is apple an
extremely desirable company to work for
for many but they also pay exuberant
amounts of money
for instance software engineers at apple
earn between 170
and 681 thousand dollars per year in
total
this isn't to say that the work these
individuals do is worth this amount of
money per se
rather rich tech companies like apple
google
and facebook left off for salaries are
far above the industry standard
this way they can attract the best
employees possible and subsequently set
super high expectations for their
employees to meet
with that being said apple won't have
trouble hiring the best ai
and machine learning developers out
there in fact
they'll probably learn a lot from tesla
as they have been doing over the past
several years
as a result it's very likely that apple
will offer a super refined autonomous
car from day one
after all their company moto is it just
works
i suspect that many luxury consumers
will appreciate this refined offering
and will choose the apple car over the
competition
for this reason moving on another major
advantage that only apple has
is their ecosystem the apple ecosystem
is one of the most popular
in the world many people own iphones
apple watches
airpods and macbooks because these
devices work together so well
most modern cars do support apple
carplay but
i'm sure the infotainment system that's
included with the apple car will be
multiples ahead of carplay we might even
see apple create a brand new software
suite for the apple car with its own app
store and everything
this might allow users to play games and
watch youtube videos while their car is
charging
also people in the apple ecosystem not
only own a bunch of apple products
but they're often also subscribed to
many of apple services
from apple music and apple tv to icloud
and apple arcade
i'm quite certain that apple is going to
nail the integration between the apple
car
and their various devices and services
as a result
many will be willing to pay the apple
tax just for the better seamless
experience
take airpods for instance wireless
headphones aren't exactly revolutionary
and you can get similar sound quality
from wireless headphones that are nearly
half the price
however airpods are by far the most
popular choice
because one they're fashionable and
they're from apple and two
they work so well with apple devices
this same principle will likely draw
tens of thousands of customers to the
apple car
every year along the lines of the apple
ecosystem
we also have apple's design language one
of the main reasons that many tesla
owners love their teslas is because of
the clean
modern interior design the design
language of tesla is often compared to
apple
and it's very possible that tesla really
was inspired by apple
in terms of design but what happens when
apple themselves
enter their car market at that point we
would get authentic apple designing cars
which may attract many next up we have
manufacturing
one of the hardest parts of growing ev
business is killing up manufacturing
but apple isn't going to be
manufacturing their cars themselves
instead they're going to be relying on
an actual automaker to manufacture their
cars
there were rumors that apple was going
to team up with hyundai
which is a questionable move but that
rumor has since fallen apart
since then we also saw rumors that apple
was working with nissan
but these two have fizzled out ideally i
think apple should work with the german
manufacturer like mercedes or bmw
to stay in line with their branding but
whoever they choose to work with
one thing that's clear is that apple is
not going to be manufacturing
themselves so they can easily cut past
most of the significant challenges
involved with scaling ev manufacturing
moreover
as we discussed at the beginning apple
is simply looking to be a niche player
so i don't think they're looking to make
more than a few hundred thousand cars
per year maybe they'll eventually get to
one or two million cars annually
but they're by no means aiming for tens
of millions of cars per year
thus they shouldn't have too many
scaling problems to begin with
anyways another reason you shouldn't
understand with tapa car
is because apple themselves is taking it
extremely seriously
apple insider has reported that apple
has over 1 000 people working on the car
this includes key players like nvidia's
former ai leaders and tesla's former
vice presidents
it even seems like johnny ive has played
a significant role in the project
before he left apple on top of this
apple has also been making several large
land purchases
which is assumed to be for autonomous
software testing in the end
all the advantages we have discussed so
far indicates that apple will be coming
out with a super refined car
that is quite practical this is great
and all but there is one more major
opportunity that apple is likely looking
to take full advantage of
which is a void in the luxury ev av
market
you see tesla is looking to exit the
consumer car market as soon as they're
able to get their self-driving
technology approved by the government
for robo taxi use
this doesn't mean that tesla is going to
go bankrupt or die
rather tesla has bigger fish to fry and
that is what they'll be focusing on
selling a car might lead to a profit of
5 or ten thousand dollars
which is great by putting a tesla in the
robo-tax network on the other hand
tesla is expected to pull one gross
profit of thirty thousand dollars every
single year
as you can see it makes much more
financial sense for tesla to shift to
owning the cars they produce
as opposed to selling them elon musk has
confirmed that consumers will still be
able to buy
tesla but it will be much much more
expensive
as in over 100 000 more expensive
as a result a mid-level tesla model s
which is likely the closest to the apple
car
will go from costing 70 to 80 thousand
dollars to 170 to 180 thousand dollars
and this is precisely what apple is
targeting
originally rumors suggested that apple
was looking to get into the robot taxi
market
as well but now rumors are suggesting
that apple's targeting private use
this is a very intelligent decision as
it doesn't make any sense for apple to
compete head-on with tesla in the
robo-taxi market
they simply don't have the manufacturing
capability or low enough prices
targeting what tesla's leaving behind
however is very feasible
given the popularity of ride-hailing
services like uber and lyft
i'm sure tesla can be very successful in
the robo taxi market
but robo taxis aren't for everyone many
people will still want to own their own
car for a variety of reasons
at the same time though whether they're
a model 3 and y customer
or a model s and x customer they're not
going to want to shell out an extra 100
to get a tesla so what are they going to
do
they're of course going to look for
alternatives average consumers will
likely flock over to offerings from up
and coming ub companies
as well as potential offerings from
legacy automakers like toyota
but what about luxury buyers well some
might check out offerings from audi
and mercedes however in this scenario
a 75 000 apple car seems like the
perfect choice for these customers
and i think this is where apple can
really win in the car market
at the end of the day while it may seem
like apple is entering the ev
av space late we have to keep in mind
that the automotive industry
is massive and that there are no
dominating players in the market
even toyota only controls a mere 10.24
of the industry and everyone else only
controls single-digit percentages
so it's not like the e-commerce space
where one company controls 50
or anything like that on top of this the
automotive industry is currently
undergoing a radical shift towards
electric and autonomous vehicles
this combined with tesla's eventual
shift to the robot taxi market
gives apple the perfect opportunity to
grow a niche profitable
automotive business do you guys agree
comment that down below
also drop a like if you guys are excited
for competition in the av space
and of course consider joining our
discord community to suggest future
video ideas
and consider subscribing to see more
questions logically answered but until
then
i'm hari and i'll see you guys on the
next one